[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
kazakhstan is a classic ex-soviet
dictatorship is a country best known for
being the homeland of borat not only
that earlier this year 2022 vladimir
putin sent troops to help maintain the
regime after protests put it in check at
first glance it would appear to be a
country absolutely loyal to the kremlin
wouldn't it however when the invasion of
ukraine was discussed at the u.n there
was a surprise
only four countries other than russia
voted against condemning the invasion of
ukraine among those loyal to putin are
lukashenko's belarus kim jong-un's north
korea bashar al-assad syria and itreya
in short the best of each house but not
a trace of kazakhstan which chose to
abstain
i don't know what many of you are
thinking now let's see grant who really
cares about the u.n and yes you kind of
have a point but in june and saint
petersburg right under putin's nose
president tokayev said this we do not
recognize
either taiwan or kosovo or south asia
or
the same principle is going to be
applied
with regard to these quasi-state
territories
which
in our view uh doughnuts can luhansk as
you can imagine this is a full-fledged
stab in the back for russia but it's a
position that is also complicated for
kazakhstan because no matter how much
gas and oil they have no matter how much
kazakhstan is the dubai of the step its
economy is completely integrated with
russia's
and in fact the kazakh oil that reaches
the european union flows through russian
territory six percent of the oil
imported by the eu-27 comes from
kazakhstan so the question is why is
kazakhstan betraying russia and how
could all of this affect europe today on
visualpolitik we're going to answer all
of these questions but first let's look
at some history
the soviet snowfall
[Music]
if there is one country that has
suffered the consequences of being in
the soviet union it is kazakhstan here
on visualpolitik we have always said the
ussr was a fully fledged colonial empire
and the poor kazak suffered more than a
little let me give you an example the
atomic bomb we all know that the atomic
bomb is barbaric right but how do you
feel about testing nuclear weapons on
your own citizens sounds wild doesn't it
[Music]
well this is what happened to the poor
kazakhs living in the inhabited city of
kirchertov where the main soviet nuclear
test site was located it even affected
the people of semi a city 150 kilometers
from there the choice of this area by
beria stalin's most ruthless lieutenant
had a premeditated objective to study
the effects of radiation on the human
body for this reason the soviets
conducted nuclear bomb tests near this
inhabited population in fact the most
important research in this field has
been carried out in kazakhstan it is one
of the few places in the world where
there are real cases of humans who have
suffered this type of radiation
poisoning
it goes without saying though that not
all soviet influence was so bad for
example kazakhstan is where the famous
baikonur cosmodrome is located in fact
the kremlin still leases this cosmodrome
from the nurse sultan government
kazakhstan russia to keep using bike on
earth until at least 2050. the thing you
may all be wondering now let's see grant
apart from nuclear bombs and space
rockets what else did the soviets do for
the kazakhs well right from the start
the ussr proceeded to convert the
kazakhs and nomadic people into peasants
for their new collectivised farms
[Music]
the result was lethal famines in the
1930s claimed the lives of 1.5 million
kazaks approximately a quarter of the
population but the kremlin knew how to
repopulate the country purges were the
order of the day in the soviet union
kazakhstan was along with siberia one of
the main destinations for the exile of
citizens bothersome to the soviet power
in addition the forced displacement of
russians also contributed to the
rustification of kazakhstan where ethnic
russians were the majority for more than
half a century until the years of
mikhail gorbachev
once again the ussr's logic was the same
as that of any other colonial empire for
moscow kazakhstan was a gigantic country
in which to develop its agricultural
plans to turn its pastures into grain
producing region for the soviet union it
was in this area that they relocated a
lot of russian population in order to
monopolize the political economic and
social elites of the kazakh republic
in fact even today russia is still the
co-official language of the state along
with kazak itself and that explains why
kazakhs are not too fond of their former
colonisers in fact we're already
beginning to see signs of
derussification
kazakhstan returned to the latin
alphabet abandoning cyrillic by 2023 but
wait a minute because this is just the
tip of the resentment iceberg that
everything russian generates amongst
kazakhs and many of you might be
thinking well it's no big deal if
they're still like this and it has after
all been more than 30 years since
kazakhstan got its independence but
there are two details we should not lose
sight of
firstly since 1990 power has been held
by nurse saltan nazarbayev that is since
a year before kazakhstan became
independent from the soviet union so the
main stakeholder for little change was
the president himself the main
transformation under nazarbayev came
with the opening to foreign investment
to exploit kazakhstan's enormous natural
resources such as its oil and gas fields
the second detail to keep in mind is
that the kazakh economy was quite
integrated with the russian one so in a
way they were doomed to get along when
russia sneezes we catch a cold kazak
proverb against this background the
kazakhs are some days pro-russian and
some days not of course russia has
always done everything possible to keep
them in their orbit
take for example the eurasian economic
union an organization pushed by putin to
sustain russian influence over central
asia when it was launched in 2015
kazakhstan had good reason to be wary a
quarter of its population is ethnic
russian and putin had used a similar
pretext to annex crimea so kazakhstan
agreed to join the eurasian economic
union by prioritizing its economic side
and blocking russian suggestions to
endow the organization with political
and defense competencies in this way the
kazakhstan sought to have their own
voice in the world and not to depend on
russia in any situation but of course
then came the revolts of january 2022
and that is when tukayev president of
kazakhstan since 2019 found himself
between a rock and a hard place
kazakh president seeks help from
russia-led security bloc of course this
intervention was a great opportunity for
russia to meddle again in kazakhstan's
affairs it is clear that president
tukayev looked both ways and the truth
is that neither the united states nor
the european union is going to help prop
up a dictatorship so he had no choice
but to use putin's wild card and at what
price though at the price of absolute
loyalty check this out
you too you brute my son
after the intervention of russian troops
to entrench tokyo and power it seemed
that relations between kazakhstan and
russia were closer than ever then comes
the invasion of ukraine and putin who's
been working for years in central asia
to build a regional bloc led by russia
supposedly expects all these countries
to support him however the stan
republics have kept a studied silence on
the ukrainian war and not only that in
addition putin has found that tokyo has
talked back to him look at how the
russian press is putting it
this is a backstab the network is
outraged by the appointment of a
russophobe as the minister of
information in kazakhstan
[Music]
the course charted by tokyoev after the
invention of russian troops shows that
the kazakh president completely
distrusts putin or rather he doesn't
want in any way to be seen as a puppet
of moscow and that is why as soon as he
felt safe in power again tokayev has
been making a lot of gestures against
russian influence and is also putting an
end to everything that smells of former
president nazarbayev why well to
consolidate on the one hand his
independent image and because on the
other hand it was the former president's
entourage that had the most ties with
the kremlin or at least that's the image
that took heaven wants to give and that
is why as soon as he could he made the
former president the scapegoat
[Music]
and so among other things he withdrew
the honors he still held such as the
chairmanship of the national security
committee and he also dismissed his
daughter who had become president of the
senate and is now no longer even a
member of parliament but tukayev has not
stopped there
kazakhstan key nazarbayev cronies
undergo apparent purge the former
president's nephew has been fired as
deputy head of the powerful security
services many of you may be asking
yourselves why is he doing all this
dokayev reportedly believes all the
serious disturbances of last january are
due to the interest of some sectors
close to the former president for the
kazakh government to open the country's
door to the kremlin and yes hokayev did
give putin the keys to kazakhstan but as
soon as the russian troops left the
first thing he did was to change the
lock
[Music]
tokayev is not making things difficult
with the kremlin because he is a lover
of democracy but due to a question of
sovereignty with the example of ukraine
tokyo is seeing what russia is capable
of doing with a former soviet republic
an invasion would directly threaten the
kazakh people but it would also threaten
his power in belarus tokyo is seeing
that supporting russia would give the
kremlin kart blanche to abuse kazakh
sovereignty
as it stands right now if putin plays
the balalaika lukashenko dances like a
cossack and no self-respecting leader
wants to be anyone's puppet by not
supporting russia the kazakh leader is
also aware that he is scoring points
with the west and western backing could
come in very handy for tokyo in order to
continue to defy the old kazakh elites
still controlled by nazarbayev the
question for kazakhstan is of course
that putin does not intend to sit idly
by while they challenge him
russia shuts down novorosis oil terminal
after kazakhstan offers to send more oil
to the eu the russian port of
novorossiysk is an outlet used by
kazakhstan to export 80 of its oil
[Music]
the caspian pipeline consortium which
manages that 1 500 kilometer that's 932
mile pipeline from the kazakh oil fields
to the black sea managed to get the
russian terminal back into operation in
july even so every now and then this
pipeline is being disrupted by russia
and this is affecting the kazakh economy
kazakhstan sees economy slowed down by
russia's war oil outputs forecasts have
been trimmed amid difficulties in using
a key pipeline kazakhstan halved its
economic growth forecast for this year
from four percent to two percent but
wait a minute visual politic viewers
because europe may also be hurt if
russia once again turns off the taps to
kazak oil that's why the european union
and kazakhstan are working on
alternatives to bypass russia how to do
it well we're going gonna look at that
right now
goodbye putin
there's only one news topic that has
been repeated in europe this summer as
much as the heat waves putin's continued
threats to leave europe without energy
winter is coming and the kremlin is
using gas and oil to make the european
union think twice about its support for
zelensky and in the middle of all of
this is kazakhstan obviously kazakhstan
is negatively affected by this every
time russia prevents its oil from
reaching the black sea on its way to
export to europe this is why talks at
the highest level between kazakhstan and
the european union began in july tokyo
is clear about what needs to be done
kazakh president calls for new oil
export roots after russia suspends key
pipeline tokoyev aspires to build a
pipeline under the caspian sea
connecting the two shores it is not the
only country in the area interested in
building a pipeline to export its energy
resources to the european market
turkmenistan also wants to do its
business with gas
[Music]
the future of both projects needs to go
through azerbaijan on the one side of
the caspian sea but i don't want to get
into the details on this matter because
it'll be the subject of another video in
the future the problem for kazakhstan is
that a trans caspian pipeline is not
something that can be built overnight
and tokyo wants solutions now for the
time being the kazaks have found a
formula that may work for them for a
while
exclusive kazakhstan to start oil sales
via azure pipeline to bypass russia as
of this september kazakhstan has begun
using a fleet of small tankers to carry
its dinosaur juice across the caspian
sea to baku there it will use the btc
pipeline which connects baku to belissi
capital of georgia and saiyan a turkish
city on the mediterranean coast the idea
is to complement this route in 2023 by
taking advantage of another pipeline
from azerbaijan to soups george's port
on the black sea but it is not a
definitive solution well no it's not
[Music]
it is woefully insignificant it is
estimated that by using these roots
kazakhstan could deliver some 100 000
barrels of oil per day barely 8 compared
to what it sends through russia this
figure could be improved if you add
another option being considered in
kazakhstan which is to send the oil bile
rail to batumi another georgian port on
the black sea but this route would also
cross russian territory so in all we are
talking about small patches to ensure
that kazak oil continues to reach europe
albeit in dribs and drabs however this
could be the beginning of something more
important a sign that kazakhstan wants
to stop depending on russia and that
means a very important change in central
asia in the meantime tokyo is wasting no
time kazakhstan leaders seek snap
elections and cuts to presidential term
surely the kazakh elections will
continue to be the same old theater they
were not supposed to be held until 2024
but tokayev wants to bring them forward
to this autumn before that he expects
the kazakh parliament to approve a very
relevant change limiting presidential
mandates to a single seven-year term
tokayev is 69 years old and cannot hope
to mark an era in kazakhstan but the
next seven years he has the opportunity
to change kazakhstan more than during
nazarbayev's three decades and this may
have important consequences for europe
so visual politic will be keeping an eye
on the situation but in the meantime the
question is over to all of you will
kazakhstan manage to reduce its
dependence on russia or will we see a
direct confrontation between putin and
tokyo you can leave me your answer in
the comments below in the meantime don't
forget that we release new videos every
week so subscribe to this channel so you
won't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know all
the best and i'll see you next time
[Music]